Where I come from
a lot of women have fake hair.
I often wear wigs or have extensions
plaited into my natural hair.
And sometimes the hairstyle can take up to two days.
It’s a lot of time that needs to be filled,
So people at the salon talk about their life.
But it’s not just the women who are here
to have their hair done.
You often have people coming in and out
just to have a chat.
It’s because you have here a level of trust
that you hardly find anywhere else.
And this trust leads to better stories.
I became a journalist because I wanted to
be a storyteller.
And I want to find those real authentic stories
about everyday people
who have something to share.
Now, with all the time I’ve spent at the
salon,
I know high quality hair when I see it
and a good story when I hear it.